welcome back It's the Most Wonderful
Time of the Year with Thanksgiving just
days away and small business Saturday to
follow and the perfect place to support
is Ferguson's downtown we have general
manager Erica Bell joining us to talk
about all of the shopping that's to be
had at Ferguson's downtown Erica so
great to see you again you too I love
Ferguson's because there is just so much
to see and do and there's always
something new to find and discover but
let's talk about what you guys have
planned for the weekend and Saturday is
a really important special day for you
guys small business Saturday is huge for
the city of Las Vegas and especially all
of our small businesses restaurants and
things like that and so with Ferguson's
having 16 small businesses within our
city block this is a huge important time
for us to just represent what we do we
have a Showcase of a lot of different
items you can you can find at all of our
different shops and then we also have uh
you know our tree lighting when it gets
a little bit dark we will have if you go
into F the bar with your receipt you'll
get a free a complimentary toddy or a
hot Coke Coco love it for all your good
work supporting local
and then uh we'll have live music on the
stage we have carolers from the LA uh
from The Academy of Arts oh my God
that's gonna be out there just spreading
the joy for everyone to just have a good
time and have great energy so that's all
happening this Saturday this Saturday oh
and then Haymaker Market is our local
marketplace where we're featuring even
more small businesses local craft makers
and artists uh and that will be out in
the yard how fun so Ferguson's is
definitely the place to be on small
business Saturday and I love the bar
that you guys have in there but just
everything about it is so cool I feel
like I just get lost in time because
there's so much to experience and can
you just tell us a little bit about some
of the vendors I mean you have so much
stuff here and just so many things to
look at when you come shopping there I
mean we cover everything we're super
blessed we have everything from health
and wellness with essential oils and
soaps and lotions even candles we have
vintage uh apparel clothing and cool
knickknacks um a more apparel plants I
mean come on you can go wild in the
plant store that's all you need a tiny
Bloom if you need that centerpiece for
your Thanksgiving table or even for
Christmas they'll have you sorted out no
problem that's a great idea yeah I was
noticing all the Fall colors here and
it's so funny we were just talking about
how we were just out at Ferguson's for
Life is Beautiful now we're in full
holiday mode you guys always have
something going on I love F the bar it's
such a cool Vibe and place to hang out
so so many things to experience see and
do be sure to go to Ferguson's downtown
Saturday I mean every day but especially
Saturday they have a lot of holiday
festivities going on so thank you so
much Erica for being here Rocky I'll
send it over to you thank you Julian